welcome to Santa's fancy party have you
been naughty or nice naughty kids we're
getting spared I can't contain my joy
right now
I do love glitter I like little at all
warning glitter can get everywhere I'm
about to get Christmas pimped out
what does the beard oil for Oh give me
that beer baby can you do me first
yeah man that's really nice to meet you
for the first I know we probably should
have introduced social pretty simple
right just put the [ __ ] on it then you
put the glitter on it then boom yes this
is what my feels feel like someone hop
open this my hands are too oily no you
can do it if you could do it
apply liberally there we go I'm scared
of breathe through my nose okay alright
so don't go against the grain that feels
nice I think my work is just coming to
life right now I don't think I did this
right
probably the only time in my life that I
will ever get to do this with anybody
you never know mm-hm your wife can have
a beer too oh my god yeah is it working
I knew you had the skin for this is it
weird that two Jews are doing a
Christmas beard
do we have to Tecna call this a holiday
beard no wait I might know anything that
comes to my face it gets all over my
body [ __ ] is on there forever I think I
went a little too far look at me holy
crap you look good what else can be done
to you it's my pot of gold it's beer
time
look at these we are crazy this is
therapeutic uh-huh that thing on my
beard we're supposed to be decorate or
beautiful those look I have a pair of
testicles on my chin I'm doing
surprisingly well merry Christmas to you
then I'm a hot barking meth right now
boom
I like you see them
and you look like a Jewish family
decided we'll do Christmas this year but
then didn't put a lot of effort in
santos' like you know when he's watching
land right like this
[Music]